welcome to episode 4 of the stronger by
science podcast in this episode Greg
shares some feats of strength I defend
myself against methamphetamine
accusations and we both discuss some
funny stuff we stumbled across on PubMed
this episode also features plenty of
talk about how dietary supplements are
regulated including an interview with
Rick Collins who is the top steroid and
supplement lawyer in the country thank
you for listening enjoy the episode
[Music]
I'm your host Eric Trexler I'm here with
temporary co-host Greg knuckles Greg how
you doing doing well how are you I'm not
well Greg I'm not well tell me about it
so Greg you know I started lifting when
I was 12 years old right yes and the
thing about 12 year olds is largely they
don't know how to lift and the result of
that is I have a pretty bum hip at the
moment okay so three of the last four
nights I've woken up with very very bad
hip pain bad enough that it wakes me up
so there's three things going on here
first of all not sleeping well sucks
I theory so that that's strike one the
second part is being in pain also sucks
so I've got that going against me well
yeah but it's also the only reliable way
to know that you're still alive
according to Linkin Park the only thing
the only reliable way so I mean it's
it's got its pros and cons now I think
number three is the one that really
strikes a nerve though okay so it's
inviting a comparison that I've been
trying to escape my whole career and I
think you know what I'm referring to but
around the time I won my second pro card
everyone was saying you know the next bo
Jackson and if there's any moment
Millennials listening bo Jackson was a
pro-bowl running back he was an all-star
baseball player he was kind of back in
the day he was like the athlete dual
sport athlete but his career was cut
short because he had a he had a hip
dislocation about hip problems so for me
it's like I respect bojack's and
everybody does he did it first
he was a great dual sport athlete and as
a dual sport athlete myself I respect
him but I've kind of been trying to get
away from that that kind of comparison
and I mean you know this when we started
working together I told I was very
transparent about my goals and I told
you straight up I want to prove to
everybody that I'm as smart as I am
athletic and handsome and the more
people drag me into this Bo Jackson
comparison it's the harder and harder is
to get up that hill Eric just remind me
again what uh what two sports are you
are you pro in oh good point because
that's another thing that kind of
irritates me about the comparison so I
am a pro natural bodybuilder and I am a
pro natural classic bodybuilder so I'm
not in that world so so just fill me in
here because I'm the ignoramus at the
table those are completely different
sports right right so like you come from
strength and conditioning yeah and so do
i and so when you start working with the
team when you're planning out a year of
training the first thing you do is
basically a needs analysis yeah so what
physical capacities need to be trained
and developed over this year yeah and so
like for you those sport it's like
comparing 100-meter sprint in the
marathon a minute in like swimming
sprints yeah yeah it's really different
there they're certainly not sports where
one could win a pro card in both of them
at the same event or if they did they'd
have to be an absolute legend the second
part yes okay yeah so yeah if you're Bo
Jackson it's like I need to train for
American football in baseball there's a
lot of overlap there but for me it's
like not too
make them metaphor but I'm chasing two
different rabbits at the same time and
as much as I respect Bo I feel like it
kind of minimizes my capacity to to
balance those sports when you say oh
it's just another bo Jackson but again
for me it's just like if I wanted to do
the route where I just said oh hey I'm
another extremely athletic handsome
person and do the whole Mike O'Hearn
brake plate thing I could have done that
but for me the whole point is I I want
to really emphasize the intellect and so
I'm just I'm just frustrated and tired
and I'm hurt and and now I'm fighting
against that and you're afraid that the
hip injury is going to just invite those
comparisons I just think I'm never gonna
get out from both shadow that's you know
maybe you should lean into it maybe you
should put Bo in your shadow I mean like
these days people talk about you know
LaDainian Tomlinson or Marshall Faulk or
priest Holmes no one talks about Red
Grange who is the first great pro
running back that's me I mean so you can
be the LT to Bo Jackson's Red Grange I'm
just gonna keep trying my best and you
know I've been doing six months of very
bodybuilding focus on going to
transition to a completely different
approach and just kind of play off the
classic bodybuilding for now and maybe
when they hit better get back into it
good luck man I appreciate it but I'm
not the only elite athlete out there you
were telling me earlier that you've dug
up some pretty incredible feats of
strength this week yes
so some crazy stuff has happened over
the past week or by the time you're
listening to this some crazy stuff
happened approximately a month ago so
[Music]
I'm gonna butcher this name but Aundrey
supposed knockoff Russian guy benched
6:01 at 198 or 270 2.5 at 90 kilos first
600-pound bench in that weight class
heaviest triple body weight bench ever
dudes obviously not drug tested but who
cares
that's it's absolutely ridiculous like
look up the video for this it's very
solid like very very good-looking
benchpress and like I'm one of those
people who quite frankly is very Pro
extreme arch in the bench press I think
you know it I think that's like the
Fosbury flop of powerlifting like
someone could be a purist in the high
jump and try to still go for the bar
forward but if they did they'd be an
idiot like the way I see it is if you
can arch for the benchpress like it's
allowed within the rules shirt take
advantage of it but if you're if you're
someone who's kind of a purist and you
want to see a reasonably long bench
stroke this this guy does actually have
a pretty long bench stroke so
aesthetically I think it will please a
lot of people as well so you you often
mention during feats of strength like
so-and-so's clearly not drug tested but
I don't care yeah
were you ever that young lifter that
like you would see the drug tested value
and you'd be like I think I'd totally
hit that if I were on drugs No so there
was so I I was actually the opposite kid
so one of the first things I ever did
that was like reported on the internet
was way back in the day I used to post a
lot on the 100% raw powerlifting forums
that's where I did a lot of my early
meets because they have a big presence
in North Carolina and I remember like
someone failed a drug test I don't know
who and everyone was like freaking out
about it and being like super moralistic
and I was just like guys like who cares
like this is powerlifting none of us are
making any money off of it like you know
you either do this sport for self
development so you're just training
against your own PR so like who cares
what other people are doing or you're
just trying to be the strongest dude and
like you know I want to be the strongest
dude I don't want to be the strongest
dude with an asterisks so like I want to
be stronger than the guys using drugs as
well like those are the numbers I'm
shooting for and like I think
you guys are making a mountain out of a
molehill here it's like I'm I'm very Pro
drugs and professional sports that's
probably another conversation for
another day but yeah like even when I
was like 15 years old that was my
perspective and then that got shared on
powerlifting watch and people were like
who's this dumb kid like you have to
maintain the sanctity of drug-free
powerlifting it's like guys like this is
our [ __ ] hobby like don't make that
big of a deal about it how our lifting
is America's pastime sure but anyway I
was I was not that kid so my reaction to
that I was always bodybuilding first
like I did a powerlifting meet but it
was just to stay interested between
bodybuilding competitions and I remember
very distinctly when I first got into
bodybuilding and made some like pretty
decent beginner gains because I started
eating for the first time in my life
mm-hmm I remember very vividly thinking
if I were to go on drugs I would
probably be Olympia level and in
hindsight I was so stupid like I was
like okay so I've gained a decent amount
of weight in the last three months if I
continue that linearly forever and also
add drugs on top of that surely I'm
going to be like at that time Jay Cutler
was like king yeah I think I could take
Jay you know I kind of feel bad for Jay
Cutler cuz like he came right after
Ronnie and I remember even during Jay
Cutler's reign which which was one of
the longer reigns in the history of IFBB
yeah everyone everyone still typically
held Ronnie up is like oh yeah this
guy's awesome like even when even when
the next dude was on top I'm like and
like I don't see people now during the
era Phil Heath saying like well man Jay
was a freak like there's not the same
wistfulness about the jay color era as
there was for the Ronnie Coleman era
yeah and then like now it's Shawn Rhoden
right yeah but no I remember I was
explaining to to my girlfriend about
Ronnie Coleman because that documentary
came out right yeah and when you're not
into bodybuilding big people just look
like big people yeah
and I was like pleading with her please
understand that this man is different
like I think part of him is nostalgia
and part of it is he truly was different
nobody liked ya Jay had no chance of
living and filling those shoes like it's
like whenever like a legendary coach
retires in a sport and it's like who's
got a coach after this guy yeah like
who's gonna coach Duke basketball when
Coach K steps down that's like the worst
job on the planet no for sure like you
have no chance or like when Jordan
retired for the second time yeah and the
Bulls had like a fire sale and it's like
well Chicago is [ __ ] for a while now
yeah I just want to make this very clear
cuz we might have some new listeners
joining in that don't get the sarcasm
I'm an absolute garbage bodybuilder and
I don't consider bodybuilding a sport if
you're still with us after like 15
minutes of me being a complete ass
that's the truth okay these are some hot
takes to start with mine I'm apathetic
towards people using drugs and drug
tested bodybuilding and your anti
bodybuilding anti body well anti
bodybuilding as a sport as the Bo
Jackson of bodybuilding so my thing so
with bodybuilding is for it I don't want
to get on a huge tangent it's it's not
that I I just couldn't be bothered
either way if you consider a sport or
not because I've seen people get very
angry at people suggesting bodybuilding
to sport and I've seen the opposite as
well you just I just don't think that
something must be considered a sport for
it to be cool and enjoyable like my
bodybuilding I I feel yeah and so to
like nuance what I was saying about
powerlifting as well is like if I
thought it had any reasonable shot at
getting into the Olympics then I
probably can
a lot more but like I think every day
that goes by it gets further from the
Olympics like the Olympics are are
considering kicking weightlifting out
and Langley yeah
because so many of the successful
countries have failed so many tests and
so like you know weightlifting has been
in the Olympics since what like 1904
something like that so it has the
history it it's already has low ratings
like that's another reason that they're
kind of willing to kick it to the curb
because you know people don't tune in to
watch weightlifting for the most part
and like I say this as a power lifter
like weightlifting is an objectively
more entertaining sport to watch like
people are moving quick it's got the
NASCAR factor as well like people watch
NASCAR for the wrecks like there's often
some some gnarly injury when you're
watching weightlifting which like is bad
but like we'll get some casual viewers
to tune in and so like as long as
weightlifting is on thin ice they're not
letting powerlifting in right and if
they kick weightlifting out they're not
doing it to make room for powerlifting
yeah like that that that should be a
clear indication that powerlifting has
no shot so like it's an amateur sport
it's always gonna be an amateur sport if
there if there were like big-money meets
for drug-tested powerlifting I would see
it somewhat differently because like
then you actually have something
tangible on the line but as long as it's
just like you know you go lift if you're
the best that just means you get a medal
that's a different color from other
people but you don't actually get
anything tangible for it like who cares
guys like just just lift weights try to
beat your own PRS and that's the way I
see it at least yeah honestly I mean
like I said I love bodybuilding and I
couldn't imagine not having it there but
yeah I don't plan to compete anytime
soon but if you told me you would never
compete again yeah I'd be like a little
bit shook by that like
it's always got to be there but um for
me it's oh I'm just intrigued by the
science yeah I just think it's wild when
I like kind of starve to death and I can
feel it and I'm like whoa what's
happening this is crazy but yeah so
that's why I've never really gotten
worked up about that that conversation
of sport or not sport I'm like I don't
know call it what you want it's still
cool
yeah fun no I feel you anyway I
interrupted you you were a quarter of
the way through our feats of strength
segment yeah so so pivoting from a very
much not drug-free person to someone who
I at least assume is drug-free competes
in the USA PL Ashton Ruska it might
still be a junior if not he just he's
very recently out of the juniors had a
2,000 pound gym total in the 93 kilo
class 715 squat 480 bench 805 deadlift
squat and deadlift both looked
absolutely immaculate probably still
more left in the tank the bench looked
really solid was touch and go probably
won't hit that much with the pause but
probably still something and maybe like
the 460 range but like goddamn he's
strong like I remember when when Jesse
Norris came out and totaled I believe it
was like 1850 way back in the day in
like 2013 or so everyone was like this
kid is untouchable went on to total 2033
in the 198 class which at the time was
just miles ahead of everyone else just
looked yeah looked completely
untouchable and so Ashton's not yet at
the level that Jesse was at his best but
like he's he's very quickly approaching
it and he's still young and what I've
heard is that he doesn't cut to make
weight so he probably still has another
4 or 5 pounds that he could gain and
still be in that class so yeah like it's
a gym total but like still 2,000 pound
total under any sir
circumstances in that weight class is
absolutely outrageous
so it'll it'll be really interesting to
see what he does in the next year or two
yeah and you've got that 2,000 pound
bias I feel like you bring that number
up often because that's that's the
number you shoot for well I mean it's
also just a nice round number it is a
very nice round number
I mean it's yeah it's just a cool number
yeah I mean it's either it's a ton in
Imperial or metric and there's a lot
more people who could shoot for a 2,000
pound total than a twenty two hundred
and three pound total you know however
speaking of people who totaled a metric
tonne Lucan all junior lifter hit a 1035
total in his first meet so that's 10 35
kilos 220 281 pounds I think he did that
in the u.s. PA which like one I think so
I think if he would have got his last
deadlift
that would have put him in the top 25 of
all time I think the the 2281 puts him
at number 34 35 all-time but again like
the students 23 he's a junior and this
is his first meet so that's how it
rageous his first me yeah I mean like
this so something something that I feel
like is still true maybe less true than
it once was but like I used to say all
the time like there's a ton of very
strong people out there that just
haven't done a powerlifting meet and
like I used to say that and people said
I was crazy and then like one day Ray
Williams shows up to some like local
meet in Alabama and squats 9:05 which at
the time he got red lighted because he
took a step forward before the rack come
in but like that would have been an
American record and I think it's still
like top five top ten drug-free squad of
all time and like when that happened I
was like ha told you
so wait that was he just came out of
nowhere and just put that number up yeah
and and the interviews with him
afterwards were wild they're just like
where'd you come from
it basically and people were like oh
what's her training like like you're you
know you're clearly the best squatter
and at least in drug drug-tested feds in
the world right now like how did this
occur and he was like he's like I don't
know man
I've just been lifting weights I really
had no idea what I could squat so I just
wanted to come out to this meet and be
able to use some equipment to see what
my max was and they're like what and
he's like yeah I was gonna try a
thousand but the bar couldn't hold it so
he had been training it like a local
YMCA or something and the most the bar
there could hold was I think it was I
think it was eight plates like 765 yeah
and so like that's all the bar could
hold so that's just what do you been
training with and once he got to where
he could do sets of 10 with that he's
like yeah let's do a meet it was
something just wild like that that kind
of reminds me I'm probably gonna fudge
the details here because it was a
million years ago and it was a dude like
actually at my gym mm-hmm so I didn't
like read about it and kind of commit it
to memory but I remember there was this
guy in our gym who was in awesome shape
and he did a master show just like you
know walked into some amateur natural
bodybuilding show and won mm-hmm and
then two weeks later took I think first
or second at Worlds mm-hmm at the pro
level and so whenever whenever people
get discouraged they've been like
working at a pro card for a while and
haven't gotten it I'm like some dude
probably showed up to that amateur show
could have been the second best body
builder in the world that day and didn't
turn pro yeah like there's a little bit
of luck that always goes into it but
yeah you never know when some way
someone is going to literally just world
class out of nowhere just walk up to a
show and like that's the thing with any
sport that's not one of the major sports
in the world right
so like there are probably people who
could be all pro football players that
have never played football or like all
pro basketball players that have never
played basketball but but what one has
to at least assume that most of the
talents out there has at least given the
sport a try
and has wound up in the NBA or NFL and
like in a perfect world if there was a
perfect talent identification system and
everyone who was the most gifted was
like forced into those sports like yeah
like they could probably get better but
it's probably it's probably doing pretty
well as is but yeah in a sport like
power lifting or bodybuilding well in an
activity like bodybuilding or to a
lesser degree weightlifting like you
can't tell me that USA weightlifting
wouldn't be better if weightlifting was
a bigger sport in the US than football
you know you just never know who is out
there that has never heard of the sport
and as soon as they hear of it they're
just gonna come in and [ __ ] everyone up
you know yeah
it's crazy yeah so now we've got one
more right we do yes so the last one is
and I'm probably gonna butcher this name
as well but Daiki could could Kodama
yeah Kodama Daiki Kodama japanese guy
bench pressed 529 at 161 so that's 240
and like seventy three and a half kilos
which this guy like he's a legend he's
been competing since 2001 so he's a
legend on two different levels he's won
a ton of benchpress world championships
he's benched
I believe 300 kilos in single ply in
that same weight class which is bonkers
he's also a legend because he is just a
binge bro incarnate so he mostly does
bench only meats he has done a few full
power meats the most recent one he
actually did this April
and he squatted he squatted 320 dead
lifted 380 and benched 490 which like I
haven't seen video of that meet but what
I've heard is that those aren't token
lifts like those are actually something
approximating max squats and deadlifts
as well via dude dude is just bench bro
for life and one of them so the the 529
he recently hit to be clear that was a
gym lift but the thing that makes that
so impressive is if he did that in a
competition it would it would tie him
with the best Paralympic bencher in his
weight class which for anyone that
doesn't know like all of the best
ventures in the world in the lighter
weight classes compete in the
Paralympics like not to be insensitive
but if you don't have legs or if you
have severely atrophied legs you can
just put on way more muscle in your
upper body while meeting a particular
weight class so yeah like anything below
I want to say like the 181 slash 183
class like the Paralympic ventures are
just miles ahead of everyone else and if
Kodama
hit that 5:29 bench in competition that
would tie him with the Paralympic World
Record which it can't be overstated how
impressive that is yeah yeah I the
Paralympic benching if you're listening
you've never watched it it's just
absolutely incredible the loads that
those guys can put on oh yeah men and
women but but yeah I mean just the
weights that they're pushing is it's
just absolutely insane as a function of
body weight yeah so just for context
probably the most at least in my opinion
the most impressive Paralympic venture
is Sharif Othman if I think he's from
the UAE no I think he's a king he's
Egyptian whatever doesn't matter so he
competes in the 123 class and he benches
for
fifty-five which is which is outrageous
well that's that's over sixty pounds
better than the non Paralympic record
which the non Paralympic record in that
weight class is 391 which is still crazy
impressive at 123 but yeah man like the
Paralympic Ventures are outrageous
I always feel stupid when I quibble
about like which incredible world record
is better than the other yeah no I mean
but both of those are just stupid
numbers but but still so like I'm not a
terrible adventure but my my best bench
I did reverse grip and that was 485 but
the best like normal like pronated grip
bench I've ever done is 455 and again
like I I'm not a particularly great
venture but I'm okay and like this dudes
doing that amount at 1:23 like I I think
I think that's the thing that that
sticks out to me like Jesus Christ that
guy's strong yeah that hurts well I
don't want to steal all the limelight
but I have a feat of strength of my own
go for it
so this is a walk down memory lane back
in the day DMAA
also known as geranium route it was in
like every pre-workout on the market
right I mean it was all over the place
yeah and it wasn't banned by anybody
like there was not a single natural
bodybuilding federation that had a band
at one point in time and so back in the
day I had always been fixated on the
300-pound bench because before I learned
about all these strong people that
seemed like a big number but one day
back when DMAA was all over the market
and it wasn't illegal and it wasn't
banned and even sport Federation's
hadn't banned it yet I got super hopped
up on DMAA
and I broke the 300 barrier what was
your PR before that I I think
I was like very focused on 300 so I
think I went for it like a billion times
so I think I had done 295 like okay okay
like a hundred times but but but it
wasn't like a 30-pound PR out of nowhere
no no no no no not at all okay but but
what happened after that was the really
interesting part of the story so I had a
drug test for an employer and I remember
when I walked out the door to go take
the drug test my mom was like you're not
gonna fail are you and I was like oh I
hope not and then I did I was supposed
to start work on Monday and it was like
you know a few days before they called
me they're like yeah we're not gonna
have you work your shift on Monday and I
was like why what did I do and they're
like well your drug test results came
back and you had meth in your yard
[Laughter]
that's ridiculous I haven't had meth in
weeks no I did not I I said surely
there's a mistake here and so what
happened was they sent the sample off to
a different lab and then they found out
that it was just structural similarity
between MDMA and methamphetamine so
they're like no you're fine I wanted but
that was probably the first time in my
life that I was like how do supplements
get regulated like what theoretically
could be found in these things and so if
you're a reader of stronger by science
we recently put up an article called
supplement regulation and the subheading
is our dietary supplements unregulated
and so it's pretty wild when you look
into it I mean like when did you start
using supplements yourself about six
months after I wanted to start using
supplements so I started lifting
all of the big guys at the gym said you
got to take protein powder that's gonna
make you big I was like okay cool so
like my parents they didn't have any
background and strength training at all
so and I said hey can you can you get me
some protein powder like from Walmart
they're like mmm are you sure that's
safe I was like I think so like all the
cool kids are doing it and they're like
well I just don't feel comfortable with
you taking that so how about how about
we get you some meal replacement shakes
that have a lot of protein so I said
okay sure like whatever we can do that I
wasn't that reasonable I like threw a
hissy fit because that's when I was like
young and hormonal and whatnot sure but
anyway so so that's what they did they
got me some insure shakes which are like
meal replacements primarily for for
elderly people yeah
and that just did not go well like
they're they're so thick they roughly
have the consistency of molasses yeah
and they says it said on the on the can
high protein but high protein was like
10 grams so you know the bros at the gym
we're saying you got to get 30 grams of
protein immediately post-workout so I
had to like chug three insure shakes
after a workout and like I would very
consistently down them feel really bad
and just like vomit 45 minutes later
because that volume of ensure you know
on a virtually empty stomach after a
workout like it just did not agree with
me and so one drinking three ensure
shakes every day wound up being
relatively expensive for my parents and
B they thought that I was just like I
don't know like acting or something like
throwing it up and I'm like no like that
I don't I don't play that way like I'm
not that invested in getting protein
powder that I'm going to induce myself
to vomit literally every day so after a
few months of that they they relented
and let me get protein powder and so
that's when I started
taking supplements now do you at all
feel guilty that you probably deprived
like dozens of geriatric patients from
the nutrition that they very severely
needed from stealing all the insure from
the store no fair enough
I I don't think that's how markets work
I think I was increasing demand in the
know I was like hey let's get into some
new flavors there yeah we got a hot
market here well yeah so the thing so
after I had that run-in with the the
methamphetamine test that was the first
time I had any interest at all in how
they were actually regulated and I think
it's really common to hear people say
like oh everybody knows supplements
aren't regulated and I mean the real key
take-home message of the article is
that's not true if you view it as a
binary thing are they regulated or not
they are indeed regulated by the federal
government obviously this applies the
United States every every jurisdiction
varies a little bit but the probably the
the second point of the article is yes
they are regulated but it kind of
doesn't matter like yeah the regulations
even when they just try their damnedest
to enforce them it's a really difficult
thing to enforce mm-hmm so yeah you know
the government's there to make sure that
companies aren't making ridiculous
claims the government's there to make
sure that they're not obviously selling
things that shouldn't be supplements but
even in those very basic things they a
lot of times they come up short you know
one of the examples of this is you
probably remember back in the day Pro
hormones were everywhere yeah I mean and
by Pro hormones you mean steroids
I need hormones yeah no but you would go
to the supplement store there were all
these basically potent oral anabolics
yeah so so just for anyone listening
like a pro hormone is something that
will get converted into a active hormone
in your body like a lot of hormones are
pro hormones so like testosterone is it
is a hormone but it's
also a prohormone for DHT for example
but most of the time if like a medical
professional was talking about pro
hormones say for for anything related to
testosterone or building muscle they'd
probably be talking about either DHEA or
androstenedione or diode depending how
you pronounce it in like both of those
if you're like a healthy person and have
normal testosterone levels like they
don't do anything they're probably just
gonna get aromatized into estrogen but
like those are those are pro hormones
when [ __ ] like super draw was on the
market like super trawl is a steroid
like like I don't know if like one tiny
thing about it is like changed in like
first passed liver metabolism or
something like that but like super drawl
is a [ __ ] steroid so like when when a
bunch of things were on the shelves
claiming to be pro hormones like if they
actually did anything they weren't pro
hormones yeah and so as a loyal follower
of stronger by science you know that we
like to be evidence-based when possible
and a couple of their really crazy
things it's one thing to say like hey
things don't seem to be enforced very
well but there actually is some
peer-reviewed research on exactly how
poorly that's gone in the past and the
the the one person who's really pushing
a lot of that research out is Peter
Cohen and so I'm looking at a study he
published I think this one was 2014 but
he basically followed up this particular
one was looking at a lot of those
anabolic oriented compounds and some
others as well but he basically said
let's go buy a bunch of supplements just
in retail locations but let's buy a
bunch of things that the FDA has already
recalled mm-hmm
for the presence of these identified
banned substances and let's just see if
we go in later and try to buy them after
the recall how much of it is how many of
them are actually fixed like did the
recall actually accomplish what they
hoped yeah so theoretically if something
gets recalled it'll either stay off the
market or when it re-enters the market
it will no longer have whatever it got
recalled for
and I'm trying to it says um they
purchase these things a mean of thirty
four months after they were recalled so
that's that should be plenty of time to
make change right thirty four months
we're talking three years yeah you can't
say it's just product that was still on
the shelves right so so the average was
about three years after when they looked
at the sample a full two-thirds of them
Oh three years after the recalls that's
great still contained one or more banned
ingredients hell yeah now another
example of like the glaring examples of
kind of shortcomings of regulation are
when it comes to some of the I guess
you'd call them synthetic stimulants
yeah some of these like non caffeine
other stimulants that are kind of
finding their way so DMAA was one of
them the FDA got some adverse event
reports the FDA reviewed whether or not
it legally met the definition of a
dietary ingredient they do you want to
get into that like how something can
become a supplement because I think
that's that's a key piece yeah so when
it comes to being a supplement it
essentially being a permissible
ingredient in a supplement product
there's a few ways an ingredient can get
onto the market so the easiest way is if
you were on the supplement market as an
ingredient as of 1994 it's essentially
got grandfathered in so 1994 was when
the united states overhauled its federal
supplement legislation and so if it was
already a supplement in 1994 being sold
and traded and and all that stuff then
it was pretty much already good to go
unless they were to find out later that
it was causing all sorts of adverse
events that they didn't know about yeah
but the general premise was well it's
been on the market already there must be
some pattern of safety if we haven't
heard about
yet and obviously it's subject to change
if if they find out later oh that was
really dangerous all along they can take
it off so that's the simplest way
another way that you can do it is you
can make the claim basically that if
it's already in the food supply
theoretically it should be good to go so
then and you can get into the legal
definitions we do that in the in the
article but you know there's some very
specific definitions that you could say
well if it's in you know present in the
food supply in a chemically unaltered
form then theoretically that that
inherently shows some level of you know
inherent safety if people have been
consuming it in food so just assuming
like fish oil supplements didn't exist
prior to 1994 you could say like look
people have been eating fatty fish
forever like we can sell omega-3 pills
right yeah because it's chemically
unaltered in terms of the form it's just
lipids from fish you can put them up in
a capsule and that that would generally
be how that goes and this is probably a
good time to put the caveat this is you
know as a scientist best interpretation
of the law I'm not a lawyer by any means
but I did have Rick Collins look at the
article in very good detail and actually
this episode we've got a full length
interview with him which is pretty sweet
but but yeah so I basically like as far
as I can tell yeah about that would be
an example of that that particular I
don't want to call it a loophole but an
exemption yeah yeah now you and you
could go another route and basically
just say I have a new dietary ingredient
and you would you know notify the FDA of
why you think it meets the legal
definition of a supplement and
essentially kind of you have to let them
know like hey this is coming on the
market and obviously they have full
autonomy to reject that Apple or that
notification if you say hey I'm bringing
a new thing to the market in 75 days
within those 75 days they could look at
and say uh no you're not
yeah but people generally don't like to
ask for permission they'd much rather
ask for forgiveness and so what a lot of
companies will do is they'll either just
say oh we're exempt from that because
this is already in the food supply and
they'll just put it out on the market
even if I don't know maybe it's not in
the food supply yeah yeah another really
awesome way to do it
this was the one that that blew me away
honestly yeah I still after reading it
after looking into it deeper after
reading FDA materials after speaking to
a supplement lawyer about it I still
don't get it
but his bet as far as I can tell to my
firm my best approximation of what I
found out you can do something that's
called self affirmed generally
recognized as safe' is the designation
and so there's this whole list of like
food additives that the government went
through like had a big committee and
said they were kind of like overhauling
the legislation of all food additives
not just dietary supplements and they're
like these are the ones that generally
were gonna recognize as being safe you
know have at it as long as it's in
reasonable amounts you know yeah so I
made this big old list and now there's
enough wiggle room in the supplement
legislation that as far as I can tell
companies can can do something called
self affirming that an ingredient is
generally recognized as safe and I guess
what that entails is basically like you
get a few people and you make a safety
panel they congregate and evaluate the
safety of this ingredient and then they
determine it safe you know I think
that's a brilliant system because I
can't even conceive of any way that
conflicts of interest could affect what
gets released well that would only be a
problem if people valued wealth over the
the public good which never happened
which would not be the case yeah so so
the thing that I asked Rick about when I
was talking to it because Rick kind of
wrote in a
a position statement for the ISSN
talking about supplements he's like yeah
companies are using this and the FDA is
not very stoked about it so he suspects
that they're gonna they're gonna maybe
tweak that language a little bit but I
was like who can who can be on this
committee and he's like ah no one really
knows and I was like well who do you
have to send the report to after the
committee meets and determines this
thing safe he's like well you don't
really have to send it to anybody
it just has to exist so like if the FDA
happens to come knocking several years
later and say hey we noticed that you've
been affirming this is you know
generally recognized as safe how'd you
how'd you come to that conclusion you
just like find some dusty old document
laying around and be like here's the
report we made six years ago so again
but that's that's wild yeah again I'm
not a lawyer I tried very hard in good
faith to understand how this regulation
works and I even if you look at the
article we go into even greater detail
about defining what's a supplement
what's not some of the loopholes
involved with the regulation but I did
have Rick look over the whole article
because frankly to be honest I kind of
didn't believe it yeah I sent it to Rick
I was like Rick surely I've
misinterpreted a great deal of this do
you mind just like leading me in the
right direction and the two options are
he either didn't read it which I don't
think is true or that's just really how
it how it is sometimes that's God that's
wild
so we we took that tangent as you were
about to talk about DMAA
oh yes yeah so that we mentioned the one
study the peer-reviewed study that
looked at so we you know try to get all
these anabolics and other banned
substances off the market three years
later they're still there now the same
researcher did a a similar study and
this one I'm looking at the publication
date it was December 2018 and so
basically
FDA after the prohormone thing was kind
of a thing of the past
theoretically then they started really
fixing their sights on these synthetic
stimulants and so the general premise of
the study is the same you know we've
gotten these stimulants that were all
banned and the FDA sent out letters and
said hey these are not allowed to be in
supplements so kindly remove them if you
don't mind and so they went back in and
they purchased some supplements in 2017
so of the 12 supplements that they
purchased in 2017 75% of them had at
least one of the four stimulants that
the FDA sent out all these notices about
and the notices were sent out I believe
three years prior so the the first study
was 67% and this one was a 75% and the
thing that I liked about this one was
that a lot of this the supplements that
they were testing they like got a batch
in 2014 and then they retested in 2017
you basically see are these things still
there but what they found was for one of
the one of the stimulants DMB a it was
not detected in any supplement purchased
in 2014
okay none of them the FDA issued a
notice about DMV a saying in 2015 the
next year they said do not put this in
your supplements and then in 2017 four
of the twelve had it now so so the FDA
was pretty much just giving an assist to
the stimulant junkies yeah so like the
FDA was telling all of these companies
like hey guys this stuff works really
well
definitely don't put it in your
supplements yeah just just to make that
as clear as possible none of them had it
in 2014 the FDA very clearly said please
stop using this in 2015 and then in 2017
33% of them now had it that's that's
great so the general premise is and and
for more detail
you know the articles up on the site
it goes into a lot of the the nuance
which with I mean that's the name of the
game with legal stuff so if I've
paraphrased anything incorrectly I
apologize profusely but the general
premise is are these regulated yes but
the companies just don't seem to care or
listen well didn't you say that a lot of
companies have just determined that it's
more profitable to pay for fines for
violating the law than it would be to
actually follow the law and thus have
stuff that gives people less of a buzz
and make less money that way it would
appear it's kind of speculation but just
mean it's so rampant you know what I
mean you would have to assume that some
people are basically making a calculated
decision of what are the odds that we'll
get caught if we do get caught what are
the odds that anyone will actually call
us out for it and then furthermore what
are the odds anyone will follow up and
truly punish us in a way that will
meaningfully hurt our business
I mean honestly dude like for a lot of
people who are really into supplements
it may be a good thing if your company
gets fined because it's like especially
with the stimulants I see a lot of
people speak wistfully about their
favorite pre-workout swear back in the
day like crazed I know was a popular one
that had some stuff that was then
subsequently banned and so like it
wouldn't surprise me if like some of
those folks are just like on the lookout
for hey what companies are getting fined
a lot like they're the ones who are
slipping the good stuff in you know yeah
I mean I remember back in the day like
in the gym
I knew friends that absolutely if they
found out that somebody just happened to
be selling a steroid in a pill they'd be
like oh no way like they would be stoked
they would go buy it yeah they let you
run out and get it before they pull it
yeah yeah actually I know I like very
loosely there was just some dude at the
gym that we have a chat every now and
then but I remember it was either a
forget if it was a prohormone or if it
was when they they finally took DMAA off
the market but he stocked up yep he was
like I'm not gonna be able to get this
again and like he like really loaded up
on it so yeah it's it's it's an
interesting world when it comes to
supplement regulation and you know even
now like the FDA keeps like talking
about CBD oil mm-hm and you know this I
you and I agree on this that like it in
terms of drugs like have at it I don't
particularly care yeah you know like so
I'm not I'm not saying but CBD oil
shouldn't be a supplement like as far as
I can tell it seems pretty harmless I
don't know but it's like sold everywhere
as a supplement and the FDA keeps coming
out and saying like hey guys it's it's
not like it's just not a supplement and
so like they're not saying they're not
necessarily saying it's dangerous but
the FDA it last time I checked which was
like a few days ago continues to contend
like seriously guys please stop selling
it as a subway we set the law and we've
determined it's not yeah yeah now in
that case I actually think the FDA might
loosen up and make it a supplement maybe
but there are some big challenges there
well why didn't someone on the front end
just say you like me and my buddies
generally recognize this is safe what so
you could do that as a means of like it
seems like that is used as a way to not
submit a new dietary ingredient
notification okay that doesn't
necessarily mean that you've now set law
you know like I got oh hey this is it's
basically just like it's almost like
asserting like oh something's in the
food supply for sure it doesn't mean it
is it just means that that's why you
didn't submit your paperwork that would
allow them to review it ahead of time
okay nice so yeah you you put it to
market and just say oh no we looked into
it but then if they if they're like well
we reviewed your document and that's
ridiculous
then they could very much take it off
the market and but yeah it
I think a lot of people are just
essentially playing a game of chicken of
like you won't first of all find out
mmm-hmm and second of all even if you do
you're not you're not gonna come looking
for my documentation probably yeah yeah
but um but yeah so with CBD oil it's
just everybody's putting it out there
and the FDA is just very politely asking
everyone to stop and they're not so I
think the FDA might try to come around
and make some kind of weird like patch
some law together and just say okay
here's how we're gonna deal with CBD but
the problem is like it's already in some
instances it's already gone through drug
approval processes yeah like there have
been like different phases of clinical
trials for it as a drug yeah and so
that's a huge problem well we were we
were at the fitness on it recently in
mighty Nelson had to talk about this I
if memory serves he said that there's
already a CBD drug on the market I
believe there is generally if something
so how do how does that work like in
something simultaneous not well
classified as a drug and so be sold as a
supplement I think it's gonna be a big
hurdle I think it's gonna be a huge
hurdle I mean I don't know I mean off
the top of my head I know that there are
pharmaceutical grade supplements that
get sold yeah yeah yeah but it's gonna
legally there's there's probably a lot
of fine print to be read there but my
very outsider understanding is once
something is a drug it's hard to undergo
a actually never mind
that's a supplement now it's a lot
easier to say hey that's a useful
supplement can we make it pharmaceutical
grade to make sure that it's meeting our
purity and quality standards mm-hmm so
like if you go to the doctor and your
vitamin D deficient they're probably
gonna get you the good stuff yeah you
know what I mean I think there's
pharmaceutical grade fish oils as well
maybe I'm not certain just because
you're being written a prescription for
something does that necessarily mean
it's a drug
I mean we're probably not the correct
people we are not at all
I look specifically at supplements and
what somebody says it's a drug I'm like
okay
not my concern then fair enough but no I
I think there's probably some legal
distinctions between a pharmaceutical
grade supplement and a drug okay so yeah
I think you can be prescribed a
supplement by a doctor that does not
necessarily make it a drug but the CBD
oil thing is it's interesting and I you
look for answers for it and frankly the
reason that's confusing and the reason
that you and I blubber around like
idiots because we don't get it is
because the FDA doesn't know what to do
with it so like the people who set the
rules don't know what to do with it so
how the hell are we supposed to know I
am stunned that bureaucrats in the
United States government aren't 100%
competent in doing their job well and be
aren't communicating to the public with
perfect clarity
yeah that that is that's not within the
scope of things that I would expect yeah
it's it's an aberration but sometimes
things happen man so with all of this in
mind if you are an athlete or you have a
job where they drug test really strictly
what are some steps you can take to make
sure you're not going to find yourself
in a Trexler scenario where you think
you're just taking pre-workout and then
you piss hot for meth all right
definitely don't take meth is the safest
option but yeah you know some people
have a lot to lose when it comes to drug
testing you know you you compete in a
sport Federation you're a pro athlete
maybe your job test if you're like
military or you know other tactical
personnel and you can't just risk it so
in that situation obviously the the
safest option is to just not take
supplements but a lot of people don't
like that that answer the second safest
option would be to rely on third-party
testing of supplements so there's a big
list of companies out there you can find
them all in the article but basically
what these companies do is they offer
independent third-party certification of
supplement products so a company could
basically say we want to get our protein
product tested and verified that it's
like clean and good to go and so it
gives you a lot more faith that the
product you're ingesting is up to the
quality standards that the certification
party sets mm-hmm but that's a really
big caveat there are different levels of
third-party certification so the most
basic one is just making sure that
essentially that the supplement maker is
following good manufacturing practices
and that's a good thing but that doesn't
mean that the product is totally clean
yeah it just means that like their
factory is not filthy and they have all
their paperwork and like they're doing
the very basic steps of manufacturing
yeah then they're not putting tainted
meth in your pre-workout exactly yeah
some Walter White great [ __ ] in there
exactly so so that's like the basic
level is like we got our GMP verified
good manufacturing practices the second
level is like some additional testing
where they make sure like okay it's like
you know doesn't have poison you know
it's not like absolutely terrible for
you which if I can cut you off right
there chef that's that's a
non-negligible issue a lot of people
aren't aware of this there was like a
Consumer Reports report several years
back looking at like the big whey
protein manufacturers that had products
on the market and I forget which brands
were the worst but like people are aware
of issues with protein like amino
spiking and whatnot but something a lot
of people aren't aware of is like
something like 20-30 percent of the
products on the market like a
non-negligible amount had dangerous
levels of heavy metals in them yeah like
you got some lead you got some cadmium
like your your your flint watering
yourself with with some of the protein
powders on the market so yeah like what
one would assume that you know the stuff
you're taking even if it's free of
banned subs like if it is free of banned
substances that it's probably safe but
like even something as basic as protein
like at least in the past in the recent
past like I want to say that was 2014 or
so yeah some pretty major issues with
[ __ ] being in there that shouldn't be
yeah so like an example that the banned
substance can call
control group the BSC G they've got a
GMP certification they've got what they
call a certified quality certification
and so that looks at making sure that
label claims are met with the identity
and the quantity of the ingredients
it'll also test for heavy metals
pesticides microbial agents and some
other things in there
so it's a step above just saying like
yeah there's no rats on the floor in the
factory and all your paperwork's in line
yeah but there's also like a third tier
and so a lot of the big companies that
do this third-party testing have this
like highest tier one and what they do
is they go step further they make sure
that you know the company is on the
up-and-up the manufacturing practices
are legit they do like the basic safety
testing and they take it a step further
and actually test for like the full wada
panel the world anti-doping agency list
of banned substances so honestly I would
say if you're at really high risk in
terms of like if you fail a drug test
you've got a lot to lose like a pro
athlete or like a world class you know
athlete or if you could lose your job
from a failed test aside from just not
using supplements I think anything below
that tier is probably too great a risk
to take so that third tier of like
making sure that the whole wada list has
been checked for and another thing
that's probably important to note is
like theoretically you might be subject
subjected to testing expectations that
are not totally congruent with wada none
come to mind but theoretically you know
so you would want to at least make sure
that whatever you're supposed to be
tested for that you're checking I do
remember for awhile the the the testing
threshold for caffeine was more
stringent for n-c-double-a than for wada
for it for a while I can't really think
of anything else yeah it's pretty
atypical you don't usually when a
company or a Federation wants to be
strict they just adopt the
policies but I'm just saying in theory
if you've got everything to lose just
double check you know and make sure that
the water list has you covered if that's
what you're relying on and really man
like as far as performance stuff goes
it's it's not that hard to just not take
supplements you know I agree I I've done
a lot of supplement research and the
more I study supplements the less I use
like yeah that's kind of telling but
yeah it's like you're gonna be just fine
even if you don't use I mean they're
helpful that there
I do take supplements yeah yeah but it
it's like one of those things if you
have that much to lose you really want
to be cautious about how much you're
taking and from where you get it yeah so
I mentioned you know I've done a lot of
supplement research in my day we've
talked about a couple a couple studies
in the literature showing you know maybe
some shortcomings of implementing some
of this FDA oversight but to play us out
a bit of a cautionary tale when it comes
to the research I think a lot of times
you know now that like social media and
fitness has devolved into just people
throwing PubMed links at each other I
think it's kind of subconsciously
reinforced this idea that if a thing is
on PubMed it's legit like it can
essentially be almost taken as fact if
it's indexed on in the hallowed indices
of PubMed yeah a lot of a lot of
stronger by science readers will know
that that's not the case right but yeah
that is that is a general perception
that's out there so to play us out we've
just got a little cautionary tale that
every now and then when you're scouring
PubMed you find some stuff in there that
you could throw as a link at someone to
prove them wrong and say they're an
idiot but sometimes there's just some
weird stuff on there Greg yes there is
so I'd like to begin I literally just
organically came across this paper today
it was
somebody sent me an article and this was
a reference in it and they're talking
about a an herbal supplement that like
frankly just does not have much like
legitimate research behind like not at
all it's an herbal supplement that's
running for president correct yes yeah
that would sure so the things that it
basically has this long list
throw out the name of the supplement now
so I don't play a loon it's Tulsi okay
there we go Tulsi yes so so no dammit
Rick's a little list here of the things
that that Tulsi based on PubMed which is
what I'm reading from here that Tulsi it
helps with anxiety cough asthma diarrhea
fever dysentery arthritis eye diseases I
don't know what that where it is hiccups
vomiting gastric stuff cardiac and
genitourinary disorders back pain skin
diseases ringworm insect bites snake
bite scorpion bites malaria its
antimicrobial which includes antiviral
antifungal antiprotozoal anti malarial
anti don't know what that word is either
mosquito repellent anti cataract chemo
preventive radio protective him at
hepatoprotective neuroprotective
cardioprotective I'm just like not even
close there's a lot of other stuff here
antispasmodic antiemetic anti arthritic
there's a lot of stuff there Greg and so
just to give an idea there is a total of
four or five references for that entire
list of stuff so this is a review paper
basically just saying these are all the
things that this thing does and when it
comes to actually providing references
for for that evidence yeah I doubt that
off all of those things have been
rigorously shown in that cumulative
total of five studies
the the rest of the paper is just a
dumpster fire as well like above that
list you're a reading from Tulsi is also
credited with giving luster to the
complexion sweetness to the voice and
false stirring Beauty intelligence
stamina and a calm disposition so I
guess that would be helpful if you're
like a podcast creator sure a little
sweetness to the voice never hurts I
think this was my favorite part as well
it was like recommending people grow
these plants in their home and it said
placing the living Tulsi plant in the
center of the household therefore has
applicability beyond the realms of
Hinduism and may play a useful role in
addressing modern-day issues through
embodying the healing power of the
natural world and serving as a constant
connection to living nature which like
that's a decent cinnamon but I think the
part I liked the most is applicability
but beyond the realms of Hinduism and
one problem I have with a lot of science
is there's so much of it that only
applies within the realms of Hinduism
and so I'm glad we finally now have a
supplement we can take that applies
outside of those realms yeah we've
really been kind of backed into a corner
even everything within that particular
realm but yeah it's just you know this
plant has cultural and religious
significance in the Hindu faith so I
want to be very very clear that we don't
mean to mock or offend or disrespect any
particular religion or you know the
people that follow it but when you're
reading scientific medical literature it
should never be hard to distinguish
between statements that are based on
evidence or based on tradition or based
on religious doctrine so I was born into
a Catholic family and in Catholicism we
have holy water I would be a hundred
percent equally as perturbed if I was
reading a scientific paper and it said
you know Hope Catholic holy water brings
vitality and good health or something
along those lines and just had
absolutely no evidence to substantiate
that claim
I mean tradition and religious doctrine
certainly have a place but it's probably
not the scientific medical literature so
I
guess the moral of the story is just
because something's on PubMed maybe they
take a peek at it yeah my example of
that recently is not to share not to
share too many details but I came across
a paper that was looking at so one of
the main outcomes was body composition
so body fat percentage and muscle mass
so body comp that was assessed via
calipers yeah not great but like
calipers are decent so no problem with
that muscle mass if you're unaware you
can't measure muscle mass you have to
predict it by taking some measurements
using some sort of regression equation
but like that's always a prediction and
sometimes you predicted well sometimes
you predict it poorly so this was a
training study and it wanted to see how
much muscle mass increased in the two
groups pre pre and post-training and the
equation they used to predict muscle
mass incorporated things like height
weight sex age ethnicity like generally
decent things to include but it didn't
include anything like you know arm girth
or shoulders or hips or like leg
circumference or anything like that a
fat thickness or anything or fat
thicknesses yeah so the only one of the
variables in that regression equation
that could possibly change pre to post
training was weight because everything
else was fixed so mathematically
necessarily if that's the regression
equation you're using to predict how
much muscle increased in the groups like
the number one way to look jacked in
that formula is just a gained weight as
fast as possible like that that is just
tautologically true because that's how
math works which like if if you're using
so like it had been validated on the
population level to say like okay like
within a population this gives you a
pretty decent prediction and so like
yeah there
there would probably be applications for
that but if you're interested in how
much muscle mass is increasing pre to
post training after a training study
that is that is quite possibly the
dumbest thing I could ever think of to
try to assess muscle mass like the
here's the thing like they already had
calipers so like there there are
equations that work reasonably well that
can be used to predict total upper arm
muscle cross-sectional area in total
upper thigh cross-sectional area based
on skin fold thicknesses and limb
circumference --is like they're not
perfect but like there are those
equations out there and they they work
fine it's not as good as something like
an ultrasound or certainly an MRI but
like that is something that you can
actually use to predict muscle mass
reasonably well so like just the fact
that that's what they went for was was
utterly baffling to me and if you only
read the abstract you would absolutely
not get that out of the paper at all not
at all yeah so yeah when you're reading
an article and and this is a it's great
that this comes up when we're talking
about supplements cuz like there are
some supplement studies out there that
are in the literature you know indexed
on PubMed that you're just like what is
happening here like it seems to very
disproportionately in my opinion affect
like some small supplement studies where
you're just like wait yeah what happened
here so when you're reading you know
some kind of like secondary articles
it's just like oh and this supplement
was shown to work as well and there's a
citation it's usually a good idea to
take just take a glimpse at it and see
what's happening you know if it talks
about how merely being next to the plant
has particularly restorative powers and
that's the evidence that the supplement
works even outside of the realms of
hinduism even outside of the realms of
hinduism yeah that's you just want to
double check and feel like okay well
there's a research link but what is the
research look like yeah so we've got a
real treat to finish up today's episode
we've got an interview
Rick Collins now Rick Collins is one of
the top lawyers in the country and
probably the world when it comes to the
laws pertaining to steroids and dietary
supplements and so he was kind enough to
make himself available to talk my ear
off about everything that goes into
dietary supplement regulation and some
of the gray areas was supplement so
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
if you've not heard of Rick Collins
that's your fault he is the the top
steroid and dietary supplement lawyer on
the planet he is frequently invited out
to the ISSN and nsca conferences to
educate us about the legalities
surrounding just about everything in the
fitness industry so without further ado
Rick thank you so much for joining us
today my pleasure thank you for having
me Eric and it's something something
that people might not know about you is
that you are a remarkably engaging
speaker quite a character and you
haven't believed in Arnold certified
Arnold Schwarzenegger impression is that
right I have done my Arnold impression
for him the first time I was out at the
Arnold Classic in Columbus Ohio probably
around 2002 having been a fan of Arnold
since I was 17 years old and a young
aspiring bodybuilder
it was amazing to meet him in person and
I was introduced to him at the Arnold
Classic and the person who introduced us
said you know this is Rick balance I'd
like you to meet Arnold Schwarzenegger
this was before of course he was
governor and I do a little impression of
him and so I don't know starstruck as I
was at the time I did just sort of
erupted out and as they he put out his
hand I said it's super fantastic to meet
you and he was like while you do an
impression of me and I'm like I do and
we went back and forth and I think he
liked it and I I wanted the chance to
spend a good part of an afternoon with
him in his office of Schatzi on Main in
in Venice and it was amazing day and so
I'm very blessed as you know Erica I
come from a background as a competitive
bodybuilder I was a personal trainer I
helped manage
gyms when I was in college and so for me
as a as a lawyer to be able to have
integrated into my practice the things
that I'm passionate about what interest
me the community that I feel connected
with since long before I even went to
law school it's a dream come true they
say that if you you know if you're doing
what you really love you're not working
and and I really do love what I do
I started this firm in 1990 and the
division of the firm that I'm in is
dedicated to the community of
bodybuilders and fitness enthusiasts and
dietary supplement companies and sports
nutrition folks so for me it's it's
fantastic and I'm very happy to do what
I do and I'm happy to be on your show so
was there a time when you realized you
wanted to do law school and then you
just kind of realized like hey there are
legal needs in fitness and somebody
needs to do this I wish I was that smart
Eric yeah
very often we we just are pushed by the
occurrence of karma into the place where
we're supposed to be so I had my a
vocation as a bodybuilder and I've got
attic full of trophies from my
competitive days and I ran a personal
training business for a while trying to
get people in shape and but that was
sort of outside the scope of my
professional journey which was going to
law school to be a prosecutor initially
and I worked as a prosecutor for five
years which is a great place to cut your
teeth and really learn how to try a case
how to handle yourself in court and then
went into private practice and the irony
is that I went into private practice in
1990 which was the very same year that
the United States Congress decided to
criminalize the possession of anabolic
steroids just by luck by coincidence
that happened to happen at the same time
that I became available as a lawyer to
folks who might run into trouble due to
that change in the law and so as a
bodybuilder and somebody who was in the
community of strength and hell
I started getting calls as suddenly
police were engaged into the equation of
intense hardcore fitness and so I
started recognizing early on in my
private practice that there was an
incredible disconnect between the guys
in the gym who had been using steroids
for many years before the law changed
without really thinking of it as a drug
or certainly as a controlled substance
along the lines of cocaine or heroin or
anything like that and the legal
community the cops the the members of
DEA the courts prosecutors everybody in
the criminal justice system who suddenly
were had to to look at this issue of
non-medical steroid use through the same
lens that you would be looking at the
use of of heroin or methamphetamine and
so I tried to begin to correct that
disconnect I started writing a column
for muscular development magazine and
ultimately the B then
senior editor editor-in-chief John
Romano convinced me to write a book
which I did called legal muscle which
was an exploration of steroids in
American law culture politics medicine
sports and so that book published oh my
god back in 2002 really became a popular
book in the bodybuilding community and I
followed that up with continuing my
column writing a lot more about it and
through that representing large numbers
of health and fitness folks in the in
allegations of either trafficking and
steroids possessing steroids using
steroids in sports and violating doping
rules or in some cases representing cops
or firefighters or other people who were
subject to drug testing who would test
positive for a performance-enhancing
drug like anabolic steroids or others
and so my entire practice now has
essentially been dominated by strength
and health and fitness and nutrition and
bodybuilding and exercise so for me it's
it's really been a complete integration
of my vocation and my avocation not
because I planned it when I went to law
school but because that's the way it
sort of evolved and if we're lucky in
life sometimes the the thing we're meant
to do finds us and we wind up where
we're supposed to be and and that's kind
of where I am Eric that's that's awesome
I mean that's kind of our before we
bring somebody on the show you have to
be a meathead first and then if you have
a skill beyond that that's just icing on
the cake so we've had a bunch of the the
researchers who were pumping iron for 15
years and then said oh you can also
research this I didn't know that so it's
perfect and you really jumped into law
at a very interesting time 1990 there's
the steroid legislation but then you
know between 92 and 94 the supplement
legislation was just completely revamped
now you've probably seen this as much as
I have I see all over the place on
articles people saying now we all know
that the FDA doesn't regulate
supplements right yeah I mean we'd see
that all the time and that's sort of a a
meme within the mainstream media and the
idea that the dietary supplement
industry is this Wild West completely
unregulated that there's no regulation
that exists and most of most of us I
would think in many of your your
listeners are aware that that's BS right
well if it were true you have a lot more
time on your hands and I Ward yeah so
yeah well fortunately it's not true
because the the supplement mystery of
course is regulated and it's regulated
in numerous ways
the FDA has regulatory authority over
dietary supplements and there are
numerous regulations and statutes that
apply the Federal Trade Commission the
FTC also has regulatory authority so if
somebody makes a misleading claim about
a dietary supplement product or makes a
disease claim or a drug claim saying
that the product will let's say cure
Alzheimer's or prevent diabetes the
government has the ability to
immediately send out warning letters or
even more aggressive actions enforcement
actions to stop a company that does that
so there's there's lots of regulations I
think what when they say that what they
mean is that the dietary supplement
industry is not regulated like the drug
industry and that is true dietary
supplements don't go through the
pre-approval process that prescription
drugs need to so if you want to launch a
a new prescription drug let's say you
want to bring a new statin to market
well you can't just throw that on the
market you're gonna have to do phase 1 2
and 3 clinical trials and you're gonna
have to go to the FDA and you're gonna
have to get that particular product
approved by the Food and Drug
Administration before you can bring it
to market with dietary supplements you
don't have to go through that
pre-approval process like you do with
drugs but you still can't launch a
product to the market unless you have
reason to believe these reasonable
expectations that it's going to be safe
and certainly if you make claims about
it that are inappropriate or illegal you
can be called to task for that and
certainly if the product hurts anybody
you can be in lots of trouble for that
and I'm sure you've seen the Food and
Drug Administration and the US
Department of Justice has taken action
against company
in the dietary supplement industry and
even in the sports nutrition industry so
a subcategory that are serious and in
some cases result in people getting
charged with crimes and indicted and
convicted and in some cases imprisoned
yeah so you mentioned there there's kind
of this the FDA has some oversight and
the FTC now the FTC has oversight
regarding claims right I'm including the
claims you might see on it on a
supplement label and a lot of times
you'll see on that label it'll say this
statement has not been evaluated by the
Food and Drug Administration is that
basically just indicating that the
statement itself is more in the
jurisdiction of the FTC no the FTC and
the FDA have somewhat concurrent and
overlapping Authority when it comes to
claims certainly FDA has the authority
to to enforce against claims that are on
a label of a product and the FPC's
ability to look at claims extends to
other sorts of marketing materials or
brochures or other things that might be
include claims about a product the
recently the FDA and the FTC sent out
joint warning letters I think it was
only last month to a number of companies
regarding the types of claims that they
were making and it was both agencies
working in tandem to send out these
letters warning companies about what
they were doing and that is an example
of sort of the the kind of ways in which
the government agencies can overlap or
connect in their policing of a market
and just because you send out a warning
letter you get a warning letter from
from FDA or FTC doesn't mean that's the
end of it the company then has to
respond to it and they have to attempt
to correct the the problems and even if
they do that doesn't necessarily mean
that that's the end of it either in some
egregious cases it can go over to a the
US Attorney's Office and an assistant US
attorney could get involved whether in a
civil enforcement action or in some
cases in a criminal enforcement action
and I've handled cases involving for
example disease claims where a company
makes claims that are outside the scope
of the sort of structure-function claims
that are permissible for dietary
supplements and starts making disease
claims and by disease claims I mean you
know making claims that a particular
product will cure cancer or will reduce
the effects of Alzheimer's or will ward
off diabetes or things like that and in
some cases the case can be turned over
to the Department of Justice and the
principle of the company can wind up on
on the negative caption on an indictment
and can risk going to prison on cases
like that
so yes the dietary supplement industry
is not regulated like the drug industry
but then again look at what we pay for
drugs right prescription drug prices are
through the roof and in part that's
because of the patent aspects of it and
it's also because of the amount of money
that needs to go into bringing a
prescription drug to market if every
company that wanted to bring a vitamin C
product had to go through phase 1 2 & 3
clinical trials for that vitamin C
product you know I don't think the
American consumers necessarily want to
be paying $50 a tablet for vitamin C
right you go get some oranges right
right no thank you
so so let me just to get the audience up
to speed please correct me if I'm wrong
on this I'd like to get kind of a
working understanding of the basic
structure so the FDA and the FTC can and
hat are responsible to regulate the
supplement market all supplement
companies are federally required to
adhere to Good Manufacturing Practices
yes and by that we mean you know and and
that was imposed a few years ago back
when the law changed in 1994 and the
Congress enacted something called the
dietary supplement health and education
Act which was the law that really
allowed suppl of the supplement market
to flourish in the way that it has since
1994 the the essence of that law was to
say that look supplements ingredients
dietary supplement ingredients dietary
ingredients are essentially what we get
out of our food vitamins minerals
different types of extracts from
botanicals we eat these things and so
they are deemed inherently to be safer
than the sorts of synthetic prescription
drug ingredients that are created in a
laboratory right so so that's the
essence of it and so the Desha or Josiah
be the supplement law effectively said
we're gonna regulate drug these sorts of
dietary supplements not as drugs but
it's food as a subcategory of food and
so that's what it did and so but at that
time there was no imposition of
standards in how the manufacturing of
supplement products would occur and so
it was a few years later that the
construction of what are called current
good manufacturing practices were
imposed on the industry and it was
phased in over time first it was the
really big companies of the industry
then the medium-sized companies and then
ultimately even the smallest companies
had to adhere to these things and so the
idea is that you can't go and make
in your basement or your kitchen and
throw a label on and market them in
compliance with the law because those
things would not be made under the
standards of good manufacturing
practices and so contract manufacturers
or the places that manufacture by
contract different types of supplement
ingredients need to adhere to these
regulations these GMP s as they're
called
and so the GMP s are what helps to
assure that a supplement product is made
under conditions that are sanitary and
where there's quality control and
quality assurance and if a product is
made outside of good manufacturing
practices in other words if somebody
just threw up some crap in a bottle and
started selling it as a supplement well
it would not be a legal product because
it was made outside of good
manufacturing practices and what the law
says is that that product is adulterated
because it's not made in compliance with
the law and B not only could the the
person who is marketing that ultimately
have to do a recall or get in in trouble
for being told not to do it but it's
actually a crime and that person can be
charged with introducing and adulterated
and misbranded product into the market
yeah so on the topic of GMP sometimes
you'll see a product that has a little
label on it that's you know it's kind of
bragging made with current good
manufacturing practices a label like
that on a product it is that like me
basically bragging that my company pays
the taxes that I own isn't that just
kind of saying like hey I don't violate
federal laws yeah a certain redundancy I
guess well yeah I mean certainly you are
bound to adhere to Good Manufacturing
Practices I guess you know bragging
about it and saying that you're doing it
is sort of
and assurance to some consumers who may
not know that supplement companies are
bound to certain standards yeah
and I guess that's part of the problem
too right is that the public is
misinformed about supplements there may
be people who maybe not your listeners
but certainly lay persons who aren't
very knowledgeable about health or
fitness may have no idea that there are
good manufacturing practices imposed on
the industry and so for them that that's
actually news and of course the
mainstream media like we talked about
before isn't helping the situation when
they continue to claim that there are no
regulations that adhere to dietary
supplements or apply to supplements and
again it's it's just simply not true
yeah so I do have some questions about
specific ingredients that are kind of in
the news but before I get there you know
we've talked about this post market
regulation right and basically if you're
putting a product to market that
contains ingredients that were on the
market when that legislation went into
place in 1994 those ingredients are
grandfathered in and you do not need
pre-approval now if you're introducing a
new dietary ingredient you would need
pre-approval was that correct we want to
stay away from the term approval because
drugs go through an approval process and
and sometimes if we if we don't if we're
not clean and neat about our semantics
we can muddy the waters a little bit so
all prescription drugs need to be
pre-approved they got to be approved in
order to to launch them
nope supplement needs to be approved the
supplements that contain ingredients
that were on the market as supplements
and prior to 1994 October of 94 when
that Desha went into effect those we
could call old dietary ingredients or OD
eyes there
grandfathered in and that's the way the
law was constructed and ingredients that
were introduced to the market after
October of 94 would be considered new
dietary ingredients and what the law
requires for the new dietary ingredients
or NDIS is a higher level of application
or review before those products hit the
market and so typically for a new
dietary ingredient you need to give
notification it's not approval but it's
notification to the Food and Drug
Administration 75 days before you launch
the product that this is a product that
you're putting on the market okay and so
that NDI notification process is
required for most NDIS now it's a little
complicated because if an NDA fits a
certain exemption criterion then you
don't have to give that notification 75
days in advance and that is there's
there's language in the law that says
that if it's an article that's in the
food supply an article that's in the
food supply in a form that's not been
chemically altered and that's that's
used for food then you don't have to
file that notification and so there the
number of notifications that have gone
out are fairly small interestingly
enough and so some companies may rely on
that exemption not to a file not to give
a notification on an NDI and and in some
cases they may be correct and in other
cases they may not but again the idea is
unless the ingredient is in the food
that we're eating
which would help establish a reasonable
expectation of safety then there would
have to be some sort of notification
yeah the the it's important obviously
that the supplements that we take have a
reasonable expectation of safety
now you mentioned the exemption of being
present in the food supply and I'm not
even gonna try to replicate you're very
careful terminology but you know what
you said we all heard it sure yeah
that's essentially the route that they
went with DMAA right like geranium route
like yeah that the idea that they claim
that exemption and then I think that's
still currently being litigated there's
still litigation yeah I think there is
still litigation going back and forth on
that although I think there was recently
a criminal matter
that in all BMAA
and part of the the basis for that as I
understand was that it's not a dietary
supplement ingredient yeah things can
get murky and there are some who will
argue that the exemption doesn't require
them to bring a particular ingredient to
the attention of FDA in advance and a
company that does that obviously runs
the risk that FDA can feel otherwise and
can wind up in litigation some other
companies are actually trying to do a
different route to bring a product to
market that was that contains an
ingredient that wasn't on the market
prior to 94 by having some sort of self
affirmed generally regarded as safe da
CR created for the product where they
have a panel of folks evaluate whether
it meets the grass or generally regarded
as safe criteria and creating a self
affirmed rather than presenting that to
FDA so there are a few different ways
that that companies can can try to bring
a new dietary ingredient to market but
certainly throwing stuff in a bottle and
and not adhering to any of these sorts
of things and not applying good
manufacturing practices is a recipe that
endanger is the public and ultimately
can result in serious enforcement action
I'm very glad you brought up this self
affirmed generally recognized as safe
concept because I was reading about it
the other day
is there any FDA guidance regarding who
can be involved in the creation of that
dossier like who is an expert that can
actually make that ruling or that
determination on behalf of a company
yeah I mean I've it's it's a murky area
where I've heard different people
claiming you know what will satisfy the
the requirements for a panel for you
know what constitutes grass self
affirmed grass as an alternative I think
FDA generally frowns upon the self
affirmed grass route as an alternative
to nd I notification for dietary
supplement ingredients and this is a
fairly new development the last few
years that companies have been sort of
doing it I would suspect that FDA might
you know some at FDA probably see it as
an end run around the notification
process and so might hold it to a higher
standard yet one of the problems is that
while FDA certainly has the regulatory
authority to police very aggressively
the dietary supplement industry the
question is always resources right I
mean how many inspectors are out there
how many audits can be done what is the
size of the resources that that FDA has
to go after the bad actors in the
industry and probably better funding
would allow FDA to do more and this is
something Eric that that is goes back
and forth as a debate in the industry
for quite some time and that is whether
we need hire new laws and higher levels
of regulation over the industry where
Congress has to get involved or there
need to be new regulations or whether
the current laws and regulations are
more than sufficient and it's really
just a matter of enforcement of giving
FDA enough money enough resources to be
able to go after the bad actors yeah and
that kind of gets back to the the
original premises you know if we ratchet
up the enforcement to a certain level
you know how much of that cost goes to
the taxpayer versus the company and at
what point if companies are bearing some
of that cost at what point do they no
longer become viable because the I mean
the profit margins on a lot of these
supplement projects products are already
quite slim are they not right it will it
depends on the product certainly you
know the pills would have typically a
higher return a better profit margin
than powders for example but yeah you're
right
you know at what point is the is the
regulatory requirement level too much
for little companies to survive on the
other hand you know there's also an
obligation on industry to do the right
thing and and to some extent to
self-regulate and that's been a problem
whether it's been you know putting aside
even DMAA
as a as a ingredient in question there
were certainly ingredients that didn't
fit the criteria to be a dietary
supplement ingredient but yet were
launched on the market and particularly
in the sports nutrition face and
proliferated I mean looking back
probably in the late 90s and Rho hit the
market right and then you had following
and Roe you had a whole bunch of other
steroidal precursor products
Andrew Steen died on being at least
arguably
in the food supply and a natural hormone
in our bodies but there were an
increasing number of steroidal
substances that were purely synthetic
that were launched on the market in 2002
2004 in that range that there was no
argument that a lot of those products
were not simply unapproved drugs and had
no business being put into a dietary
supplement product and you know one of
the interesting things about the sports
nutrition market is that a lot of the
consumers really don't care whether the
product contains something that fits the
definition of a dietary supplement
ingredient or not the question is will
at work you know and if it if it will
add you know 10 pounds of muscle in over
a period of time or give me an extra
half inch on my biceps then you know
give me two bottles and so you had the
pro hormone market really took off and
if you remember there were congressional
hearings about how it is members of
Congress just couldn't wrap their heads
around how is it that these steroids are
sold in a bottle and and marketed as
dietary supplement products what's wrong
with with the law and that was even
talked about modifying supplement health
and education Act but ultimately there
was instead a a new law that was passed
in 2004 to try to crack down on the
prohormone market which was a failed law
if you remember it it was a new
incarnation of the 1990 anabolic steroid
Control Act that listed a bunch more Pro
hormone products a bunch more
ingredients but didn't really change the
catch-all and so what you had was after
that crafty chemists in the dietary
supplement industry just came up with
new steroidal ingredient and brought
those to market and it worked until
December of 2014
that the designer anabolic steroid
Control Act was passed and signed into
law and at that point now the the pro
hormone market was pretty much decimated
by an expanded definition of what a
supplement what a what an anabolic
steroid is and included a lot of
supplement type ingredients that had
been on the market yeah and so do you
think that new legislation in 2014 has
essentially wiped out that whole Pro
hormone and a designer steroid kind of
market pretty much pretty much because
it really it talks not only about the
structure of ingredients but it talks
about marketing issues as well so it
really has cracked down enormous lis
but it's interesting you know there's I
say to people about narcotics that
whether you whatever laws you put into
place for addictive type narcotic drugs
there's a certain percentage of the
human genome that wants to get high and
however you legislate it however you
enforce it it's probably gonna be a
similar percentage because that's you
know people
it's simple demand and supply and so
it's one of the reasons why I think the
the war on drugs which we've now put
well over a trillion dollars into since
it was declared by by President Nixon
has really done very little to reduce
the demand for narcotics and in the same
way frankly I think there's a certain
percentage of the human genome that
wants to get jacked right and that
demand is going to be there regardless
of what Congress FDA DEA or anybody else
tries to do and so case in point the
when the perform
industry was was really knocked down in
you know by the the various incarnations
of the amended laws you had the growth
of this new product line suddenly new
substances were hit to replace the pro
hormones and those worse arms so you had
widths arms market and 15 years ago most
people in the fitness industry had never
heard of ass arm and now with the
creation and testing of a nobis arm
Osteen you suddenly had this new class
of chemicals that were not steroids that
were not regulated by the designer
anabolic steroid Control Act but
purportedly had somewhat similar effects
to steroids on performance and
hypertrophy and so suddenly you had ass
arms market that really got pretty large
and pretty out of control for a period
of time and it's just another example
that the consumers continue to demand in
the sports nutrition space products that
build muscle and and so even now as as
thus arms market and Psalms being
selective androgen receptor modulators
most of your listeners are probably
familiar with this class of substances
that selectively stimulate the androgen
receptor in bone and muscle without
stimulating the stuff you don't want to
stimulate right I mean right there would
stimulate things that we don't we don't
we want to leave alone you know the
prostate nobody needs a bigger prostate
you know it's fine just as it is right
nobody needs their scowl
to be stimulated to start losing hair
nobody wants more back hair right nobody
needs some acne on their back so by
selectively stimulating only the areas
that we want muscle bone it's it's a
cleaner more direct way to build muscle
and so a lot of bodybuilders jumped on
the bandwagon a problem of course is
that these are drugs they don't fit the
definition of a dietary supplement
ingredient they have no business being
on the dietary supplement market and so
and some of them are being researched as
prescription drugs others have no real
research into safety or efficacy and so
you know you're you're dealing with the
great unknown and obviously if if these
are unapproved drugs effectively they
are they shouldn't be being sold and
purchased over the internet but that
that has happened and and we're now
beginning to see some enforcement
actions about that and some folks being
prosecuted over that and arrested and so
you know it's another example of sort of
the darker side of the sports nutrition
industry which you know continues you
know based on demand yeah now the SARM
thing is interesting because you
mentioned it did kind of once Pro
hormones were out of the game thus arms
kind of moved in is that SARM market
starting to contract again as the FDA
sends out more letters and actually
pursues criminal charges he board or are
they steady still pretty prevalent out
there I think what happens is it's a
bell curve where a a class of
ingredients that is questionable or if
not downright illegal begins to get
traction and the when some companies
start getting out there and making some
money that others start jumping in and
be
or you know it there's a flood on the
market and then a few start getting
targeted with warning letters or as we
have recently heard even some
indictments and you know and a week ago
right right and then little by little
the the risk takers begin to get cold
feet and they start getting out of it
but I guess if we learn anything from
the history of the sports nutrition
market it's that consumers demand
products that make them leaner bigger
stronger and so when one category
contracts if the demand for the effects
continue a new category will replace it
I don't know what's gonna replace arms
but if you look at the history of the
market something will yeah and that's a
great point you mentioned things start
going away when they catch heat and new
things come in we kind of saw that with
kind of the long term history of pro
hormones and designer steroids once
certain compounds were catching a lot of
heat they would just tweak it and come
out with a similar compound right we've
seen something like that with the
stimulant side of things I know Peter
Cohen at Harvard has published a lot of
studies finding first he focused on DMAA
but now in the last couple years or last
few years a lot of similar stimulants
that probably don't fit the FDA
definition of supplement right it is
your sense that the a lot of those
stimulants have kind of seen their day
now that they're under the spotlight or
is that still a prevalent concern yeah I
think that I mean if you want to even
take it back a step
there was a fedra right back in the day
and you had this this herbal stimulant
product that you know was derived from a
botanical that that people been using
for centuries
and millions of servings across the
country used but FDA had reports of
adverse health effects and in in 2004
FDA banned ephedra so you had this
stimulant this fat burner that people
were you know demanding that was now off
the market and I think DMAA you know
what the 1-3 dimethyl was a would became
sort of the the go to you know the
substitute for when when ephedra went
bye-bye
and then as DMAA got more and more heat
from the fda you then had as you said
these alternatives so you had diem be a
you know an analog close closely related
chemical and then you had b MP EA and
these other sort of substitutes for you
know to meet the demand of people who
want a pre-workout or a stimulant
product or a fat-burning product but as
you you alluded to fda doesn't like
these other ingredients either
and so fda actually did send out warning
letters with respect to both of those
ingredients FDA even sent out warning
letters a couple years ago on methyl san
Efrain and saying that it's it's it's a
misbranded product in Taine's that so i
think we're going to continue to sort of
see folks coming out with a pre-workout
stimulant looking for botanicals that
that may have some an ingredient that is
effective and what those will be i don't
know i've heard you know talk within the
industry that different folks are coming
out with - a compliant stimulant
ingredients
and I think that that will continue to
be sort of one of the one of the two
Holy Grails in the sports nutrition
industry something that is a dish a
compliant but effective pre-workout
fat-burning stimulant ingredient and
something that is a - a compliant
effective bodybuilding you know hi
perfect hypertrophy stimulating
ingredient Oh that'd be gonna be huge
right now every time you hear an athlete
and in some cases even you know people
who are subject to employee drug testing
you you hear about it more with athletes
but it's almost like the automatic
response of a failed drug test is
tainted supplement right right yeah
how often is that an easy scapegoat and
and how often do you actually think
that's a credible excuse well I've done
a lot of drug testing cases I've
represented student athletes in NCAA
doping cases I've represented
professional athletes I've gotten many
many calls from folks who have failed
drug tests and want me to look into how
they failed it and they'll tell me you
know Rick I I didn't take what they're
claiming that I tested positive for I
don't know how it happened and I want to
fight it I want to try to you know
appeal this finding and the drug testing
system the anti-doping system that we
have is interesting you know like I said
I come from a background in in criminal
justice as a prosecutor and then as a
defense lawyer where you're presumed
innocent right you know and it's unless
and until you are found guilty beyond a
reasonable doubt you have or you're
cloaked in that presumption of innocence
with these drug testing cases that the
way that the anti-doping system works is
sort of the opposite you are tested and
if your a and your B sample or both
positive for some metabolites in your
body that suggests that you took a
banned substance you're basically guilty
and your remedy is an appeal without
ever having had a trial you're now in a
position of Appeal and we're usually in
criminal justice you have to have a
guilty mind we're what we call Ben's
Raya you know or it's some intent or at
least recklessness or knowledge in drug
testing it's a different standard it's
what's called strict liability meaning
basically if that substance is in your
urine you are accountable for it and it
doesn't matter how it got there it
doesn't even matter if you didn't intend
for it to be there and so that's a tough
standard strict liability is a very
harsh standard and basically you're
accountable and it's very hard to win on
an appeal now there are situations where
certainly athletes take a drug let's say
an anabolic steroid and then try to
claim that they took a supple it's kind
of like the dog ate my homework right
excuse right you know everybody wants to
blame the supplement and what percentage
of that is true I don't know I think
probably in in most cases if somebody
tests positive for a substance that's a
performance-enhancing banned substance
it's probably because they they took it
but that doesn't mean that it's true for
everybody right and I have seen many
cases where people didn't intentionally
take something and they tested positive
and we've even seen that in the news the
first one was kicker Wenzel Olympic
swimmer many many years ago who took a
multivitamin and tested positive for a
steroid due to quality control problems
in the manufacture of that product and
he sued and he won a ton of money in a
lawsuit again
the company that was responsible for
that product because he wound up losing
his Olympic opportunities yeah yes no
Hardy another Olympic athlete who was
actually a pitch person for a particular
supplement line and then wound up
testing positive for clenbuterol which
is a beta-2 agonist a uses a
bronchodilator in some countries but
banned in sports because of its
stimulatory effect she winds up testing
positive for clenbuterol and and they
find out lo and behold it was in the
supplement that she was pitching for
yeah so it does happen I represented a
pro boxer a few years ago called Sam
Salomon the number one ranked
middleweight boxer in the world who
fought the German champion Felix Sturm
in Dusseldorf Germany beat the daylights
out of them and then tested positive for
methyl son Aaron and he had no idea how
he got methyl son Aaron in his body
because he didn't take anything that
would have caused it and we found out
that there was a supplement product that
he took that was the source of his
positive and and so it does happen that
there are quality control issues of a
number of years ago I actually
represented a individual in a criminal
case who had a dietary supplement
company and was actually intentionally
spiking his pre-workout products with
clenbuterol in the after hours when
everybody else had left the
manufacturing facility he was putting
some in there in order to give some
extra bang for you know some bang for
the buck in his stimulant products and
ultimately it was confirmed and he was
found out and he wound up needing to be
held accountable for it in a federal
criminal case so these things do happen
there are quality control issues
whether it's at the manufacturing level
at the world material level whether it's
in some cases intentional spiking or
mislabeling so athletes can test
positive and one thing that that folks
can do there are some certification
programs that will offer a seal that
suggests that the product has does not
have banned substances at least because
there's been some testing done for those
sorts of banned substances I know
informed choice as a program NSF has a
program the banned substance control
group has a certification seal that it
offers two dietary supplement companies
as a third party service so if you have
a sports nutrition product and you want
to make sure it is it is not going to
have a positive effect on a drug test
you can submit your products to one of
those companies and get a certification
and that at least lets drug test that
athletes know what to look for if
they're in the marketplace for a product
and you also sometimes recommend holding
on to a dose or two of your old
supplements in some cases is that right
I do I tell people that just based on my
experience so you may wind up finishing
a particular product and then you throw
the bottle away and now a month later
you wind up being asked to submit to a
drug test and you test positive and then
you come to me and you say Rick I need
help I'm being charged with a doping
violation and I didn't take what they're
saying I took and and if we look at and
we we see a well this is an ingredient
that I've sometimes seen in dietary
supplement products as a contaminant in
trace amounts and that could be the
source of your positive give me the some
retained samples from what you were
taking give me a list of what you were
taking and I can send it out and I
typically will send it out to Oliver
Catlin at the banned substance
group and Oliver will we'll do some
tests on the product and if in fact we
find that the product was contaminated
with the exact substance that caused the
positive were in a pretty good shape to
either get a and exoneration in some
sports or at a minimum a reduction in
the in any sort of suspension even
though it's in the urine if I can show
that it really was something the athlete
did his due diligence on or her due
diligence and it was a contaminant you
you can have some success in in any
sports in in doping appeals but when
you're told by the athlete well I threw
everything away I don't have any of that
well that that makes a problem what I
usually do is if there's a bit of us a
retained sample I'll have it sent over
to Oliver and if that tests positive
then I'll be able to also look on the
bottle and see what the batch though the
lot number is for the product and I'll
go out and try to get a sealed container
of the same batch and also have that
tested so that we can rebut any argument
well you know you just sprinkled a
little of that substance into the
product in the bottle into that powder
or into a capsule in order to make it
look like the product was laminated so
I'll try to get a sealed bottle at the
same lot but if you threw everything
away
I can't even know what batch a lot to
look for right so so for people
listening along we've kind of
established it's been a I mean an hour
of just gold and audio a lot of good
information here we've kind of gone over
how the FDA has the and the federal
government in other areas as well the
ability to regulate this industry we've
talked about things consumers can do
using third-party certification
retaining samples so at the very least
hopefully we can get this out and help
people realize exactly the what is where
oversights provided and where some of
that burden is on the consumer now my
final question for you we've talked a
little
about kind of cleaning up the the
enforcement in terms of oversight do you
think it is just enforcing what's
already on the books just allocating a
little more funding or do you think more
legislation is needed down the pipeline
I think there's enough legislation on
the books to cover the vast majority of
problems in the market and overall if we
really compare the the negative health
effects the risks involved and
contaminated products and things like
that there's lots of problems in the
food chains supply chain as well as well
as prescription drugs we've seen recalls
of prescription drugs we've seen all
sorts of problems with Salmonella and
food and other things though I think
they wrong - like twice a week now I
think that it seems that way so I guess
the point is you know while sometimes I
think that certainly there there are
issues and problems in the sports
nutrition and supplement industry there
are some bad actors but I think they're
typically not the norm I think it's a
small percentage of bad actors and if
you look overall the supplement industry
is not this Wild West as it exists today
with GM ES and everything else and I
don't think that we need to hammer it I
think comparatively this dietary
supplement market is safe as compared in
some ways to both food and to drugs and
so I don't think we need more
legislation I think we have enough I do
think that there might be some
amendments to the law when it comes to
certain ingredients and I'm thinking
specifically about cannabidiol as you
probably know one of the biggest
developments in the dietary supplement
ingredient widely but even now into the
sports nutrition industry is TBD CBD is
a
peirong now in major retail health food
stores drug stores are now carrying it a
local mom-and-pop drug store north near
me has a whole wall of CBD products the
problem of course is that FDA says CBD
is not a lawful dietary supplement
ingredient you can't sell it as a
dietary supplement ingredient according
to FDA yeah and there's some
developments there's a new law the farm
act of recent farm act of 2018 which
which takes some of the some of the
problems away from selling CBD at least
takes the DEA out of the equation for in
in most situations but that doesn't mean
that the FDA has backed off its position
and so there's a very fertile area for
potential legislation regulation
potential enforcement in the area of CBD
and I I'm now getting calls and my firm
represents a lot of companies in the
sports nutrition space from startups to
establish businesses who are looking to
do the right thing we're looking to
comply with the law who want their
products to be in compliance with Desha
to be made unto good GM fees and who'll
call me and say Rick I want to introduce
a CBD product what what can I do and
what is the current law about that and I
want to put it in my post-workout or my
pre-workout and certainly there's
interest in CBD and sports nutrition
because of the potential for the
enhanced recovery and anti-inflammatory
effects those are sort of what what the
sports nutrition companies are looking
into and looking at but there are
problems because right now the way FDA
sees it CBD oil is not a lawful
ingredient and there are also problems
with potential drug testing because
obviously THC which is also a compound
found in cannabis which is the same
plant that hemp and marijuana come from
and obviously CBD is an extract from the
hemp you know cannabis yeah but if you
test positive for THC you can wind up
losing either a sports ability to
compete in sports or an award that
you've won in sports or even your job
because if you're a cop or a firefighter
of you're on probation and you're taking
a CBD product at this point there are
questions as far as how much of that
product you can take before the trace
amounts of THC in that CBD product might
cause you to test positive for THC right
I tell you what Rick there are several
things I love about you but one of them
is that I had a list of things to cover
in this podcast the final one we hadn't
gotten to with CBD and see I'm also a
mind reader Erica which is one of my
hidden talent yeah in the 11th hour
you just glaze it in there I think it's
probably because I've learned everything
I know about regulation from your
materials so I think it was uh it just
had to go that way well thank you so
it's been an absolute pleasure having
you on absolutely I had a great time I
appreciate you having me on the show
Eric and if any of your listeners want
to see what I'm up to the places they
can find me if they're in the supplement
industry supplement counsel and counsel
is co u n SEL dot-com supplement counsel
com is a good place to see what I'm
doing I also still maintain my site at
steroid law.com and steroid law comm is
a place where you can really get a
handle on what the laws are with respect
to anabolic steroids and it also has a
blog as the supplement counsel
that kind of keeps people posted on new
things I've written and new things I've
done and I've got a very active
Instagram account at Rick Collins esq so
if you're out there and you're on IG
please pop by and follow me I appreciate
that I have a Twitter feed and and you
can even find my public Facebook page at
Rick Collins online Facebook backslash
Rick Collins online and hopefully I wish
you an enormous success with with the
show Eric and hopefully I I can come
back again I'd look there is an open
invitation and if you're listening along
all those ways to get in touch with Rick
check them out because as you've
probably picked up in this episode the
supplement landscape is ever-changing
and if you understand it now in three
months the whole thing's probably going
to be different it's there's going to be
new ingredients that are in grey areas
new findings so keep an eye on
everything Rick puts out what he puts
out is the legal standard when it comes
to steroid law and supplement law thank
you so much for listening along and we
will see you guys on the next episode
thanks for listening to the stronger by
science podcast now Greg and I are not
experts in medicine or health or really
anything else for that matter so before
you make any changes to your diet and
exercise habits make sure you check with
a doctor or another health care
professional if you enjoyed this podcast
and you'd like to support it visit
stronger by science com2 check out the
products and services that we offer
thanks for listening and we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you